اما في الحرب الاوكرانيه انسحاب هنا روسي
من مناطق واسعه في اوكرانيا مصرن وجب
السير على خطاه من اجل تحرير المزيد من
المدن كما اعتبرته كلاب وفي موسكو الامر
لا يعدو ان يكون اكثر من اعاده نشر القوات
التماشيا مع ظروف الشتاء وبين صيحات النصر
في ثياب وواقعيه لكريملين الميدان لا يزال
مشتعلا ولا شيء يحيي باقتراب الهدنه روسيا
تبحثوا منذ مده عن نقطه الضعف وجدتها تلعب
عليها
شبكات الطاقه الاوكرانيه استهدافه تزداد
حدتها كلما اقتربت درجه الحراره من الصفر
تعرضت محطات الطاقه لاكثر من 300 هجوم من
خلال الاسابيع الاخيره مدن الاوكرانيه
عديده بلا كهرباء وماء مثلا 70% من السكان
دون كهرباء
الاستراتيجيه ضروريه وان جاءت متاخره
مصادر عسكريه روسيه تتحدث لكن ما هو
الرابط بين كهرباء اوكرانيا
اسماء الطاقه في اوروبا
لنعود الى الورق قليلا
كهرباء الاوكرانيه من دون نشاتها تعد جزءا
من الشبكه الروسيه كان هذا قبل اندلاع
الحرب اما بعدها ولتجنب الانقطاعات تم
ربطها بالشبكه الاوروبيه لكن وللمفارقه لم
تستورد كيب الكهرباء
بلفضلته الى اوروبا السنه يكون في 15
مفاعلنا ورثتها اوكرانيا من الحقبه
الصوفيه الفائض في الانتاج الناجم عن
الخلل الديموغرافي بلغ عدد السكان
اوكرانيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي في
2:50 مليون قبل ان ينخفضه الى ثلاثه
واربعين مليون العام الماضي قبل الحرب
باقي ايام من هذا الرقم في البلاد الان
سته وعشرون البقيه اما نزحو او ضمهم
لروسيا سكان الاقل كهرباء فائده
بينما قطعت روسيا الغاز عن اوروبا صدرت
اوكرانيا الكهربائيه الى رومانيا ومندوبا
الان وبسبب الضربات الروسيه صار الامر
مستحيلا من بلد مصدر الى مستورد ملعب جديد
على اوروبا ومتى في الشتاء
اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا باستخدام الغاز وسيله
للابتزاز لكنها تطمح في الوقت ذاته ان تحل
محل موسكو كمورد قاري للطاقه كيف تطرح
نفسها كبديل يقدم في الوقت الحالي 15
مليار متر مكعب اضافيه من السعه
الاحتياطات الغاز الاوروبيه اما في
المستقبل فترى انها قادره بقوتها النوويه
وانكانياتها المتجدده مما في ذلك
الهيدروجين والغاز الحيوي ان تحل ايضا
محله روسيا لكنه وسط كل هذا التفكير
الاوكراني في مستقبل الطاقه فهي تعاني
اثار الحاضره ومن الشتاء الذي يبدو انه
سيكون قارسا استهدافه روسيا لمنشات الطاقه
يجعلك كيف عاجزه عن توليد القدر الكافي
للاستهلاك وهنا المفارقه يعمل الاوروبيون
على مدها بالمواد والمعدات اللازمه لاعاده
لعمليه في المحطه